make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up
and uh make sure you guys hit the like
button if you enjoy the video and yeah
let's begin okay
so in light of the phoenix movie or i
guess the dark phoenix film coming out
one of the questions that i get a lot is
the question of who would win
phoenix versus galactus like who would
win between these two these two
characters
um this is kind of a funny situation
because
marvel's done this really three times
that i'm aware of
um the one of the first times was based
on
a what if story where jean grey fought
galactus and the battle was a stalemate
uh the second one was where jean grey
fought galactus
in marvel generations and uh galactus
one
then there's the third time which is
actually incontinuity
um the reason why i say marvel
generations doesn't really seem to be in
continuity is because one those were
filler stories and two like
when marvel generations ended and we
went to the post-marvel landscape
where i guess going into marvel legacy
there was no reference of any kind
really to generation so for the most
part it might as well have been treated
like it didn't exist
um but the the story that's in
continuity actually took place in
excalibur number 61.
now at the time this was rachel summers
who possessed the power of the phoenix
and not jean grey
uh so i guess take it for what it's
worth those of you guys who are
unfamiliar with this
rachel summers has like a really weird
history in marvel comics so the idea
behind this is that rachel
is the the daughter of cyclops and jean
grey
from the days of future past reality
right you know where like the the
where maura mctaggart senator robert
kelly and professor xavier were all
assassinated
and uh that led to like the jump
starting of the sentinel program after
the supreme court ruled that
mutant registration was unconstitutional
and so because of that
sentinels basically became self-aware
they became autonomous and they came to
the realization
that because humans or because mutants
are the next step in human evolution
that mutants are ineffectively human you
know are in effect human and as a result
uh they decided to enslave everyone
right so like everybody in north america
was basically held captive by
uh by signals you had a couple of uh
resistance forces like you had wolverine
in canada who was trying to relate to
resistance force against uh
against the sentinels for the most part
it didn't matter it didn't really make
any difference um
at the end of the day i don't know if
they ended up nuking the sentinels in
days of future past i know that there
was a
tie-in for it with secret wars although
i didn't read it
um but nonetheless you know the fact
remains that at that point in time
in that future uh rachel had sent the
mind of kitty pride into the past right
and said like your job is to find a way
to stop this
kitty pride successfully did it but the
question became
if kitty pride's mind was sent into the
past to stop a future that technically
doesn't exist because of her actions
then how could she have gone back into
the past in the first place right and so
because of that uh it ended up being
that rachel summer's
reality the days of future past became
an alternate universe where nothing was
ever fixed
the assassination happened and all that
kind of stuff took place and so it
didn't really make any difference
in an effort to figure out why rachel
came back basically back to the present
day right like to the point
before her reality diverged and became a
different universe
and that basically led to the events of
rachel summers being thrown into the
main marvel universe
now a few things happened over the
course i mean there were stories like
dean's a future present right
we're like oh crazy franklin richards
came back from the future as well
uh but uh rachel summers ended up
joining excalibur the british superhero
team some stuff took place
and then she became the new host for the
phoenix so she's one of three people
who successfully achieved the title of
white phoenix of the crown meaning they
could use 100 of the phoenix forces
powers
of course you have gene you have rachel
and then i think it was emma frost
either it was emma frost or quentin
choir maybe four and maybe that
maybe four people maybe the quentin
choir achieved the white phoenix of the
crown
quentin choir was a super powerful
telepath right he used this drug called
kik
in order to amp his powers up basically
steroids for uh for mutants but
nonetheless uh well i guess mutant
growth mutant growth hormone is too but
regardless of the circumstance during
the events of excalibur number 61 when
uh rachel summers has the phoenix
uh she ends up running into galactus and
the way this plays out she's just kind
of flying through space
and and and she comes across this planet
which is teeming with life and like
galactus is feeding on it right and so
the phoenix is like hey you can't do
that this planet has people on it
uh you can't consume this world and
galactus is like but i can though and
i'm going
to and so basically like a fight breaks
out between the two of them now in this
this whole
conflict that takes place while phoenix
wins
it's not really due to overpowering
galactus but it kind of
is um the fight for the most part is
pretty intense it's a cosmic level fight
so like it's it's pretty hardcore
but basically what ends up happening is
galactus relents and the reason for this
is galactus makes this statement and he
basically says
like you are brimming with what's
essentially infinite power right like
you you possess
an unlimited amount of power so you can
fight forever whereas i cannot i have to
constantly replenish myself
and so it was really more that like
phoenix wore galactus down in like a
battle of attrition
as opposed to like overpowering him
outright so i imagine people will
probably use that as a means to kind of
split hairs and say well
she didn't technically win you know so i
want galactus to win but whatever the
case is
uh in that particular scuffle phoenix
came out on top right like she
essentially defeated galactus
um now at the end of the day uh galactus
it was it was kind of crazy galactus
made this interesting case
where he basically said like you are the
the sum total of all life that has does
currently does and will ever exist
in throughout the multiverse and the
omniverse right and the phoenix is like
yes and he's like okay
so basically like the universe is finite
it has a beginning point and it has an
end point
you sustain yourself by essentially
feeding on that life and so you're
basically doing what i'm doing but on a
much grander scale
people like there are beings in this
universe that will not be born because
you basically strip them of the life
that was needed in order to to exist
right so like you prevented them from
being born because
you exist more or less it's it's weird
and it's kind of a finicky argument and
it's
just sort of haphazard and at the end of
the day the phoenix ended up just kind
of being like oh my god you're right and
then she just takes off flies into space
and galactus consumes a planet
but but as far as i'm aware um and i
could be wrong here i'm again i mean i
know a lot about marvel but i don't know
everything
as far as i'm aware that's the the only
real incontinuity fight
between the phoenix force and galactus
that actually answers the question right
i mean
you could go with marvel generations you
could go with what-ifs but the issue
with that is there's so many different
variables right like there's no real
classification no real no and no real
indication of how powerful that
character is
in relation to like the main marvel
universe because that's the standard
people use right like you know right
wrong or otherwise
um people usually use that as a way to
one either cook the books in favor of
their argument
or two use it as a means to provide like
an actual sound argument but
the fact remains like like it's it's in
this instance it's not really an
arguable
or debatable point it's simply this just
that like galactus
uh really more gave up than anything
right like actually kind of like i can't
fight anymore just
was was essentially exhausted and worn
out and that's because of the difference
in the nature of their powers
one of the things to bear in mind when
it comes to cosmic level beings which is
to say
beings that can manipulate some form or
the entirety of the universe
uh using their own powers you're talking
about a level of power this extreme
and nine times out of ten it would
really just kind of boil down to a
stalemate right like
it's like saying you like like five more
than infinity how do you have five more
than infinity infinity goes on forever
when you're talking about a being that's
powerful enough to turn planets into
into giant you know baseballs and to
uh turn stars into like giant lamps you
know
when you have we have a person that has
that kind of power to all to to
essentially like
fundamentally manipulate control and
alter the very fabric of the universe
itself and everything in it
how do you determine who's a victor on
that like how do you determine who wins
like i altered reality more than you did
i mean it's i guess you know but it's
it's
you know it's it's you know it's one
more reality altering you know i altered
reality one more than you it it gets
kind of weird and it gets kind of crazy
because it's such an extreme level of
power
all it really comes down to is can one
like blink the other out of existence
before
you know before the other one does does
that to them i mean i don't really know
because it's such an extreme level of
power
right it's just it's it's bonkers i mean
you know at that point like for the
average person looking at that there's
no differentiation now
for people of that level there is kind
of a kind of a degree and this is really
like where the difference comes into
play
is galactus has an insane amount of
power right like a lot just can do all
kinds of things he can recreate planets
he can he can
create stuff out of thin air i mean he
can he can alter the fabric of the
universe if he wants to he can resurrect
people from the dead we've seen him do
that before right like bring people back
to life
bring things back to life to transmute
the physical structure of another being
using nothing but his own power right i
mean you look at it being like
apocalypse he uses technology to do that
right like apocalypse
uh creates this four horsemen by using
celestial technology to modify their
physical structure
he did the same thing with mr sinister
right like nathaniel essex was just a
normal guy and then like apocalypse uses
power to like
you know transform his physical form and
turn him into mr sinister
but with galactus it's just a wave of
his hand you know and then like
norn rad becomes a silver surfer so uh
when you're talking i mean
that kind of power is extreme right but
like you look at the phoenix and it's
basically
all of that same power except now it's
limitless and that's the difference is
galactus power is not limitless it's not
infinite right it's the it's the nature
of its character it's this one weakness
that if galactus goes long enough
without feeding one he'll go into a
frenzy which is actually kind of cool
when you see galactus like going like
when you see like a a
starred galactus uh in the comics like
he goes
balls out like it's it's cool to see him
fight when he's in that state
um he fought thanos like that actually
thanos ended up overpowering him but
because it was you know he was so
astronomically weak
uh but you know when when you when you
look at galactus like the weakness is
that if he goes too long without eating
he'll actually die
right like his energies will just kind
of cease to exist because galactus isn't
really human
galactus is composed of pure energy
that's why his form changes whenever he
appears to a different race right like
they see him
as a mirror of themselves uh so if he
showed up to like the cree the cree
would see galactus as like a giant cree
with a big purple helmet
uh but nonetheless because of the fact
that his powers are not finite despite
you know with them being like
as as wild and and capable as they are
they will run out whereas the phoenix is
an infinite source of power
so long as everything that exists
continues to exist the phoenix will
continue to have
an infinite source of power because
everything will die and then everything
will be reborn it would just have to be
something where like everything just
kind of ceases to exist
never to come back again right i mean
it's it's kind of crazy normally i don't
like really using this as a source but
the marvel handbook kind of confirms or
really just outright confirms that
phoenix being like an omniversal entity
so um a lot of people were just kind of
like you know how do you make that
justification well because marvel said
it's true so that's that's that's how we
know it's true
but um but nonetheless with with that
kind of a with that conflict
it's pretty straightforward and it's
answered in the comics right i mean it's
it's you know there's
for the most part a definitive answer
there i mean i imagine there'll be some
efforts to debunk it i don't know how
you really like debunk
a factual explanation in a comic um
unless you said i guess you know marvel
comics is wrong i'm right
in which case i imagine you probably
lose all credibility at that point but
uh but nonetheless you know it's just
it's one of those interesting battles
that people ask for
that we've already had an answer to you
know now here's the thing marvel could
shift that and that's that's the
important thing to bear in mind when it
comes to comics
things change on a whim right so just
because something is a standard now does
not mean it's a standard forever
you know it's it's it's just the way
things work um marvel could come along
and have a story where like the phoenix
fights galactus incontinuity which is to
say
in the existing universe the main line
of comics and it's referenced to you
know multiple times
um and then like the phoenix wins so i
mean you could see it play out that way
it could happen any number of ways but
at the moment in the interim right now
um as far as i'm aware uh and again you
can do your own research if you want to
but as far as i'm aware
the only time that phoenix and galactus
fought in the main continuity and
marvel's main continuity
was in excalibur number 61 and the
phoenix one the phoenix basically
outlasted galactus
so uh anyway answer to your question
hopefully that that you know gives you
guys a
good source to go to if you guys are new
here to comments explain make sure you
guys hit the sub button to become part
of the rob for if you guys enjoy this
video
make sure you drop a like and i will
catch you all later
peace
[Music]
you